that that's that's like a girl is
[ __ ] beautiful as hell no wonder
where she's just bent over booty spread
out and a guy [ __ ] comes up and has
sex with her she's like oh my god I
can't believe you did that
hey what the [ __ ] did I give a great
example do my brother's ex-girlfriend
she was [ __ ] moving [ __ ] in and out
of her car right moving [ __ ] in and out
of her car like yes it was that night or
some [ __ ] left her key fob in the car
broad daylight
all of all of her [ __ ] [ __ ] in there
and then she gets her [ __ ] car jacked
yeah and she goes I have the worst luck
that's not luck [ __ ] that's stupidity
that's stupidity you dumb [ __ ] that's
not [ __ ] worst luck on what the [ __ ]
are you talking about how dare you say
that's luck you know what luck is bad
luck is bad luck is you looking into a
boat captains eyes and he says in 20
years that I've done this there has
never been a single wave that has ever
gotten onto this boat and then that wave
dodges everybody on the boat hits you
directly in the mouth and soaks all your
equipment very bad then your camera goes
yeah whisper smoke comes out that's bad
luck [ __ ] alright I when that [ __ ]
happened to me on a boat I tried to give
the boat captain a tip he wouldn't take
it
he said I'm okay bro you keep that for
yourself cuz I lost my phone and my
camera that day oh my god that's bad
luck I don't want to hear you leaving a
key fob and all your [ __ ] in your
[ __ ] car oh my god and then you say I
had the worst luck ever I can't catch a
break no you can catch a [ __ ] case
for saying some that stupid know without
stupid people though we wouldn't have
these funny stories well that's right
they're so true that that's what I
that's what I love is like I mean I I
sound [ __ ] bothered but I'm not you
know we just talk like hello emotional
but it doesn't make me lose sleep or any
[ __ ] I think people are the most
fascinating and in an interesting things
on earth especially me I mean I'm I'm
living a [ __ ] movie like in my own
brain right like cuz like I have my
logical brain but I also have my animal
brain right and it's like I have this
part of me that is observing everything
that's going and this other part of me
that's like gorillas that can't control
it yeah it's like you witnessed this I'm
like okay I think I'm done gambling and
I take three steps [ __ ] do a 180
slam that [ __ ] on red and I said
200 on red and guess what it goes on
black and I go [ __ ] I've seen this will
come up so hard in gambling and we're
he's like I'm done for the night I'll
turn away all I hear is his distant
Japanese boy is it lose all this [ __ ] no
matter what night
thrill you love the [ __ ] thrill dude
I do and that's my impulsive stupid
human side yeah what's that the ED or
whatever I forgot what that what the CID
the ego in the super-ego
yeah but I forgot which one is which but
you got one of those [ __ ] and
that [ __ ] is on gas a red rip
reptilian brain yeah yeah you definitely
like the whole gambling side man I think
that's just like a huge part of you that
you're gonna be dealing with for the
rest of your life I also gamble with a
lot of other things in life including
eating out hookers most people go all
you should do is having sex you should
have just had sex with her and I'm like
I know I shouldn't have done it my mouth
went down there and I went to town why
do you know how many dicks that have
been in there do you know how I don't
know I gambled then I got tested euro
clean so gamble and i won right good why
would you do that why why would I'm the
only [ __ ] [ __ ] that tries to have
romantic sex with the [ __ ] process
[ __ ] yeah yeah let me eat that [ __ ] out
it's like what dude she should be
servicing me god damn I'm an idiot she's
like I don't know I don't you know how
this works sir
no but you get it's like I pay her to
[ __ ] please her and [ __ ] god dammit
she just feels great you don't matter
you let her know everything's okay it's
like let me listen to your problems here
like I'm like the therapist that [ __ ]
pays the patient to listen to their
problems
that's so [ __ ] Wow [ __ ] hilarious
and in the whole time in my mind I'm
like this is not a smart thing to do
but it's the thrill and the chase that
makes it feel good I don't know yeah
it's in its I'm like I'm like I'm yeah
I'm - two people living in one man and I
think that's the fascinating and funny
thing about humans it's like you have
this genius everyone has this genius
that knows what the [ __ ] is right and
wrong and all this stuff but they also
have this gorilla that just does
whatever the [ __ ] they want that stupid
grow that shits in their hands and
throws it on people and pees all over
and jacks off in public and like that
gorilla is [ __ ] hard to control me it
is you know what's interesting I think
for me because I grew up with like such
like bad temperament issues I think the
more I trained I thought I was gonna
call me down more it makes me want to
fight more Oh cuz it's triggering your
anxiety more in addition it's like oh
[ __ ] like I don't looks like white why
do I like even Nixon ecstatically you
have a lot of [ __ ] hate in your heart
dude you know somebody tags you you try
to you try to sleep them like corian
revenge man I know it's like awful he
hit me hard viola I have to win yeah but
it's [ __ ] acting like it was a peanut
butter jelly sandwich god damn it what
is wrong with me look after does she
gave you buddy she gotta have this this
is for you can't even take her tip and
she's like oh next time come back again
[Music]
never in my life you just become the
talk of the town just like as for him
he'll pay you and then he'll service you
something's wrong with him
I don't know it's just in the heat of
the moment